Dominic is in Atlanta hi Dominic how are
you hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up I'm so excited to be
talking to you right now I just have to
say that and I do know that you're the
only man I can talk about in my house
and my husband doesn't get upset
well I'm no threat that's why how can I
help today so I have a question about a
situation that we're in right now we've
been doing the Total Money Makeover for
about eight months now and we've paid
off almost $10,000 in debt
good for you ever we're in a really
sticky situation right now I sold my car
we only have one car that had a loan on
it was my car the balance was about
$3,200 and it had a $235 monthly payment
so we decided to sell it for $6,000 and
buy a cheaper car that was paid off kind
of save on that 235 on our budget okay
well that turned into a nightmare in
this car isn't a financial nightmare
it's draining everything that we have
we've only had it for about a month and
the car has stopped working three times
already it doesn't work at all as of
last night I've taken it to get fixed
twice I'm getting told different things
about what's wrong with it and now we're
at the point should we take it - it's a
Hyundai so we're wondering should we
take it to the Hyundai dealership and
have them fix it but they're saying it's
going to be 120 dollars per hour just to
do a diagnostic not even to fix the car
and we just don't have that money and I
just don't know what to do we've have
almost no money left in our emergency
account because of this and another
emergency we had and we're just really
stuck in a hard place right now okay so
you paid off ten thousand dollars how
fast in eight months very good okay
thank you well that's a lot more than
$1,000 a month right yeah okay
and so just stop paying extra on your
debt until we get this car thing solved
and let's just pour some money on this
car until we get it either fixed or sold
you may have bought a bad car I don't
know um now there's two types of things
that happen when a car breaks there's
the actual brain
down in the actual repair and there's a
part where you get really pissed off
about your car being broken and
sometimes when my car is broken it feels
like it's a ten thousand dollar repair
because I'm so mad because I'm stuck and
I can't go where I want to go and
wouldn't it was really a hundred dollar
repair but in my mind it felt like
there's ten thousand so what is wrong
with your car I'm not sure I took it
back to that we bought it from a repo
company we took it there to get replaced
they said it was a crank fuel sensor
which was keeping the car from turning
on he fixed that it worked for one day
the car stopped working the next day
which was another mechanic and he said
all it needed was the key to be
reprogrammed because the anti-theft
system is kind of wanky right now so he
did that car worked for one day
car doesn't work the next day okay so
that's a real mechanic was wrong take it
back to him again and say you were wrong
and tell me what's really wrong with
this car part of fixing a car is it's
like part of it's like diagnosing when
you're sick it's a little bit of an
imperfect science you sometimes you have
to work on one or two things and rule
them out and then move on down the line
it's not you know these guys aren't car
whisperers they can't look at it tell
you exactly what's wrong with it every
time they think they know but so far it
hasn't sunk you they reprogrammed a key
and put one little switch on it what was
the root what was the cost on those two
things um to reprogram the key with a
hundred dollars oh yeah we paid twenty
dollars to get another key from hande so
we're we're at about three hundred
dollars in car repairs that doesn't
exactly sink you whoa
so you're exaggerating no well three
hundred dollars doesn't sink you when
you got rid of a $235 payment you used
to have save the thing is we don't have
any money in our emergency accountants
well then that's the problem you
shouldn't be paying extra on your debt
you're supposed to have $1,000 in your
in your starter emergency fund three
hundred dollars shouldn't drain $1,000
we did have $1,000 but we had an
emergency last month that took the money
out heck but that wasn't even or this
clown yeah okay so you're you're laying
all of the emotion on this car because
you don't really like the car and I'm
okay what the car
to keep the car it's actually a really
good car and I can't believe we got the
car for that cheap outside of affected
as a start right now I want to keep the
car and I want to fix the car at so many
hundred dollars it's not you told me
this car was breaking you three hundred
dollars did not break you but we don't
know what's wrong with it those days
that's wrong because you don't have any
money right now I don't know what to do
get back to the guy that did the key for
a hundred bucks and time it didn't do it
and let him look at it and try to figure
out what it is maybe another three
hundred dollars fixes it but in the
meantime you got rid of a two hundred
and thirty five dollar payment and so
far you've only spent three hundred
dollars getting this car almost working
and yet it's not working spend the money
to get the car working stop paying extra
on your debt until you get the car
working don't take it to Hyundai for one
hundred and twenty dollars an hour to
figure out what's wrong when all you've
done is spin when all you spends three
hundred orders to start with you're
overreacting
calm down it should it's the cars just
broken you're mad and I don't blame you
I told you that earlier when my cars
broke I get mad I don't like it and I
want just get rid of stupid thing but
you don't have the money to do that you
need to just go spin two or three
hundred bucks and get it fixed you don't
have a $235 payment anymore so there's
room in your budget and you've been
paying off a thousand dollars a month in
excess of that in debt so there's room
in your budget to spend a thousand
dollars a month on this car and never go
into debt and really never you know put
you any further behind that then you
were you're still ahead if you spend a
thousand dollars this month instead of
reducing debt by a thousand dollars
you're still ahead on this car and I
doubt it's going to take a thousand
dollars get the car running so just calm
down
you